bonsoir france comme michel lambert
merci d'être avec nous en direct ce soir
sur rtl france pour vous est-ce qu
emmanuel macron donne des réponses
portent aujourd'hui aux propositions des
150 membres de la convention citoyenne
je pense que le problème de emmanuel
macron c'est un problème de ne pas avoir
saisi ce que c'est que l'écologie c'est
une forme de pensée c'est aborder le
monde différemment aborder le monde par
rapport à ce que nous sommes nous sommes
finalement que matière dans une dans un
univers dense sur cette terre et non pas
à côté dans des calculs économiques dans
des calculs de relations de business
d'ailleurs il a bien dit le 4 % je le
repousse le 110 km heure je le prends
pas emmanuel macron c'était le médecin
qui vous a soigné les jambes ou plutôt
fracassé la jambe gauche puis la jambe
droite
il essaye de les soigner tant bien que
mal l'écologie c'est un autre médecin
qu'il nous faut c'est celui qui pense
tout le corps qui pense au niveau de
comment nous comportons on peut pas
avoir une personne qui ne sait s'occuper
que de fractures aux jambes pour
s'occuper de notre problème global qui
est tout notre corps est donc emmanuel
macron ne saura toujours à côté de la
plaque sur l'écologie donc moi je ne
mets aucune intention de de croire en
quoi que ce soit par rapport à ce qu'il
va mettre en oeuvre justement on en
reparlera après on va pas les aborder là
parce qu'on va en parler en détail les
municipales bon c'est un signal à cette
convention 15 milliards d'euros pour la
transition écologique la proche pour lui
aussi de la présidentielle vous pensez
qu'il ne va pas justement changer son
fusil d'épaulé alors qu'il voit après
ces élections les rebelles et
municipales que les français ont à coeur
la question de l'écologie
la question de l'écologie on confond
toujours la première à tiques
environnementale le problème évidemment
au contraire ont changé depuis trente
ans en écologie mais c'est une façon
d'aborder notre société de la solidarité
peut-être ce qu'on appelle la low tech a
comparé à son idée lui la start up
nation où toute la technologie va nous
sauver on a bien vu que ce sont plutôt
des hommes et des femmes qui nous ont
sauvés du coc vide que une application
qui est tombé en rade qui s'appelle stop
qu'ovide on a bien vu que c'est les
régions c'est la proximité c'est la
solidarité
que les grandes le grand capital qui lui
n'a apporté que quelques jeunes
l'hydraulique et parfois des masques
mais pas l'organisation sur le terrain
c'est les premiers de corvée et pas les
premiers de cordée qui sont la vraie
résilience de notre monde c'est ce sont
les maires locaux
c'est parce cette verticalité
jupitérienne là emmanuel macron vérifier
comprend pas il ne peut pas c'est
comment vous expliquer et ce n'est pas
dans sa capacité par rapport à ce qu'il
a développée et je le respecte pas parce
qu'il a développée au cours de son
histoire et qui riche de comprendre que
c'est à notre format de monde que l'on
pourrait rapporter à ce qu'a été
l'humanité depuis la nuit des temps et
qui cds structurés au xxème siècle lui
il est resté bloqué dans la frange de
l'humanité qui est le 20e siècle et non
dans ce cas était l'humanité depuis que
lé humanité alors françois michel
lambert nous allons justement évoquer
ces municipales 1 strasbourg on a vu les
images au mans bordeaux lyon les verts
ont remporté des villes symboliques en
france
illustration à lyon où il signe un
doublé avec la mairie et la métropole
après 19 ans de règne de gérard collomb
valentin carpentier avec des images
d'elle mais ce carballo c'est en
vainqueur que grégory douce et s'est
présenté devant ses militants
leurs représentants d'europe écologie
les verts a largement été élu maire de
lyon grâce à son alliance avec le ps
la france a soumises et le parti
communiste un moment historique pour le
nouvel élu lyon avait rendez vous avec
l'histoire
la voici lyon est au rendez vous nous
sommes au rendez vous
lyon a choisi l'écologie alors on peut
dire lyon et fait de cette étoffe danse
ont tissé des rêves
malgré 62 % abstention l'élu écologiste
a devancé le camp du maire sortant
gérard collomb qui devra se contenter
d'un poste de simple conseiller
municipal un tournant pour la troisième
ville de france qui tourne une page
longue de 19 années de règne
son nouveau maire a bien l'intention
d'en faire une référence lyon va devenir
une référence et nous ne sommes pas
seuls dans cette aventure
grenoble est aussi elle aussi
écologistes ce soir tout comme bordeaux
strasbourg marseille et bien d'autres
villes encore seul ombre au tableau une
interruption de la soirée par des
militants pour l'hébergement qui ont
demandé une prolongation de la trêve
hivernale jusqu'en mars 2021 pas de quoi
gâcher la fête pour un des nouveaux
représentants de la vague verte en
france
mais françois michel en grève qui est
toujours avec nous vous vous attendiez à
un tel succès des verts notamment dans
les grandes villes françaises
or c'est les verts etc l'écologie en
général un qui réussit alors peut-être
pas un tel sujet soyons honnête par
contre ce que l'on ressent d'abord ça
fait un moment que le vrai nouveau monde
c'est justement celui qui est inscrit à
notre approche un autre logiciel c'est
ce que j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure et
il a émergé beaucoup plus vite
après cette crise du coc vide la crise
que nous avons subie bata seul coup tout
le monde s'est rendu compte il nous faut
on a pu l'alimentation on n'a plus les
médicaments
on nous parle et c'est emmanuel macron
je souhaite que vous fassiez vos
entreprises que vous gagnez des millions
que vous puissiez avoir des ferrari
alors qu'en vérité ce sont des gens qui
utilisent le métro quand ils
fonctionnent et qui nous ont permis de
survivre de survivre et donc que autre
chose à se mettre en oeuvre et c'est
bien là proche des écologistes qui
certes ne va pas flamber ne va pas vous
dire demain vous aurez une belle ferrari
où vous irez en vacances tous les ans
voire trois fois par an aux seychelles
aux maldives et je ne sais ils vous
disent non vous aurez peut-être à tout
ça mais vous aurez une vie riche riche
de de solidarité de liens avec les
autres et mais aussi de lien est ce que
nous sommes
parce que les
sommes nous sommes une partie de cette
vie qui est sur la terre nous ne sommes
pas à côté de la vie donc nous devons
retrouver un équilibre avec vous
décrivez est ce que ce sont les verts
les écologistes qui ont ce monopole là
on peut être socialiste on peut être les
républicains et avoir ce genre d'idée
que vous êtes en train de développer un
jeu on peut être avec des valeurs
approchante et ceux qui sont les plus
proches sont évidemment les valeurs
progressistes qui se situent
essentiellement à gauche il ya aussi un
progressisme de droite je ne le nie pas
mais les républicains qui sont sur
d'autres approches plus
d'entrepreneuriat plus d'individualisme
plus de réussite personnelle et non des
approches collectives
comment voulez vous qu'ils comprennent
ce sens de du lien ensemble comment
voulez vous qu il m qu'ils ralentissent
décroissance d'entreprise qui nous
détruisent pour permettre à chacun de
pouvoir suivre et ne pas détruire la
planète ça ne s'est pas dans leur
logiciel cci c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre le transformation du monde
elle se fera par une approche qui nous
remet en lien avec ce que nous sommes
nous ne sommes pas des extraterrestres
cette planète nous sommes une partie
prenante de la vie sur cette terre et
nous devons avoir des logiciels décembre
de pensée de solidarité comme il en
existe dans la nature entre animaux de
différentes espèces parfois qu'ils
arrivent à survivre dans des espaces
très contraignant au milieu des déserts
au fin fond des océans
parce qu'ils savent s'entraider et non
s'entretuer pour quelqu'un qui soit plus
gros que les autres mais quand il est
plus gros que les autres et il a tué
tout le monde et ben y meurent parce
qu'il est dans un environnement hostile
et bien c'est ça la vie sur la terre et
c'est ça l'humanité qu'elle doit
construire demain sinon nous risquons
effectivement un effondrement de
l'humanité et je rappelle que c'est ce
que dit edouard philippe
donc je lui demanderais d'être en phase
avec ses propres propos et de
complètement changer son logiciel aussi
s'il peut françois michel lambert ne va
pas entamer ici à un débat sur le
nucléaire est une petite question parce
que c'était l'un des événements aussi
écologique de la journée une page se
tourne à la fermeture depuis le temps
qu'on en parle de la centrale de
fessenheim
une bonne chose pour vous enfin puis
c'est une bonne chose parce que la
france est le pays avec un taux de
nucléaire est extrêmement élevé l'hyper
technologie qui va nous sauver
sauf qu'on a vu des catastrophes
tchernobyl fukushima qu'on n'est pas
passé loin nous mêmes de catastrophes
qu'on est devant peut-être aussi un
black out parce que le coc vide à
retarder dé maintenance de centrales et
donc peut-être qu'à l'hiver prochain
voir l'hiver d'après des centrales ne
seront pas disponibles et donc d'être
dans l'hyper technologie on en revient
toujours la même chose on se coupe d'une
réalité l'énergie elle est partie
prenante de cette terre elle est partie
prenante de notre vie sur la terre c'est
pas l'hyper technologie mais c'est
plutôt l'accompagnement l'accompagnement
que les énergies renouvelables le
solaire l'éolien la biomasse mais aussi
de ne pas surconsommer
donc c'est bien des approches
écologistes que nous devons avoir et non
des approches technologiques que peuvent
être le nucléaire la réalité elle est là
et je crains que même la france soit en
difficulté en termes d'approvisionnement
énergétique à cause d'un petit virus qui
aura retardé pendant deux ou trois mois
l'entretien de nos centrales nucléaires
et par voie de d'effet domino à l'hiver
prochain et l'hiver suivant
nous n'aurons pas assez de puissance
nucléaire parce qu'on a tous fondé sur
une technologie 75 % d'électricité
française voilà voilà c'est ça que nous
devons complètement changé sans parler
des risques d'accident malheureusement
on l'a vu et malheureusement d'autres
arriveront sur cette planète j'espère
pas en france on peut le craindre parce
que bon nous restons le pays avec le
plus de réacteurs au monde
rapporté au nombre d'habitants